so you want to see this circuit breaker
just explain the thinking behind it
so what we're saying is that a circuit
breaker for two to three weeks
would mean that we would be able to halt
and
reverse the spread of the infection
right across the country
we could use that time to boost our lab
capacity to put proper local tracing
processes in place and then we
would have that breathing space which
would
uh buy us time really uh and stop the
the real danger that our nhs faces that
our hospitals are going to be
filling up far too quickly over the next
few weeks and and so it would really
give us the chance to to reset
and and take a step back before this
virus really spirals right out of
control
at the same time though you can see why
people are pretty skeptical that any
circuit breaker would actually last for
two to three weeks i mean there's a
reason that andy burnham calls these
hotel california lockdowns because it
does feel like you never actually get
out
once you're in them are you really
saying that after two or three weeks
if hospitalizations are still going up
if deaths are still going up then labour
would just say
okay that's fine let's just lift the
restrictions
i think it is really important not to
waste the period of a circuit breaker
you know it's not just everybody goes
home and stays at home for two years to
three weeks and then we come back out
again and
as you say then there would be a real
risk that that's not quite the question
no
but but well no but the answer is to use
the circuit breaker period
to take the measures that have been
identified as being effective in helping
to manage and bring down the spread of
the virus
and what we can see already with the
local lockdowns i mean here in
manchester
we've been in a local lockdown um of
sorts since the end of july
rates are continuing to rise with the
measures we have now they're not working
so we have to try something different
that's the point isn't it
the restrictions in manchester haven't
worked for 11 weeks and that's why they
haven't been lifted
they've been increased and that's why
people are very skeptical that if you do
impose a two to three week lockdown
it's not going to be lifted after two or
three weeks is it you can't guarantee
that
well nobody can guarantee what's going
to happen in what are the most
uncertain and unpredictable
circumstances why are you saying that it
should be just
because we know what makes a difference
what actions need to be taken during
those two or three weeks
to begin to bear down on the rate of the
spread of the virus we know
that tracing contacts of those who have
tested positive
is absolutely crucial to managing the
virus two or three weeks
would give us time to put better local
tracing processes in place
we know that swift testing and getting
the results back swiftly
is key to managing the spread of the
virus two to three weeks would give us
time
to invest in and boost our lab capacity
of course i recognize
uh that we would um have to look at
the impact of the um the
circuit breaker and and it will take
time to feed through
but the the risk of doing nothing is
even greater frankly
if we do nothing at all we know
inevitably uh that we are going to see
this virus and the rate of spread
increase and increase our hospitals fill
up
and sadly more deaths what i am
struggling to get my head around is that
you know you
have opposed stricter regional lockdown
so you put a press release out saying
that in 19 out of 20
areas they hadn't worked and yet you're
also calling for stricter measures as
well
i mean are you just trying to have your
cake and eat it here i don't really
understand the consistency
no not at all and one of the many
problems we've got here with the local
measures is the confusion that people
have
between what's what they can do here
what the rules are elsewhere
and also the lack of support that's been
put in place so that
people are very worried about the impact
of further
measures here um on their livelihoods on
their jobs and on their businesses
that's why we think we need a holistic
solution a solution for the whole
country
that also recognizes that although here
in greater manchester
we have um alarmingly high rates of
infection
and rising uh other parts of the country
are seeing the same
trend right across the country the
spread of the infection is rising
and that's why we think we need national
action now
before the situation gets worse gets out
of control
becomes really dangerous right across
the country
and that we have a proper package of
support wrapped around that
circuit breaker so that people know that
their livelihoods
and their businesses will be will be
looked after it's not really true to
suggest that greater manchester has got
the say
similar rates of covered as elsewhere
there was that the rates in
areas such as the north west are far far
higher than in other
parts of the country i'm just looking at
for example 9 out of 10 boroughs in
greater manchester
have seen the rate of covered infections
increase in the last week
hospitalizations in greater manchester
now higher than at the start of the
national lockdown in march
on current trends in two weeks time
there'll be more cohort patients in
intensive care in manchester
that at the peak of the first wave so
surely
should go to manchester now go into tier
three of restrictions
i'm absolutely clear that we must have
measures here
that address what is an absolute public
health emergency for us you're quite
right to highlight these really
terrifying figures and it's important
that
measures are taken really swiftly and we
need a deal
very very quickly and if it's going to
be a local
arrangement between the government and
local leaders here
but we do need that deal to include
proper support for people's jobs for
their businesses for their livelihoods
because if that's not put in place
alongside tougher restrictions
we know the restrictions won't work
people will not be able to they won't be
able to afford to shut down their
businesses they won't be able
uh to afford to stay at home and isolate
when they need to
it is so important that action is taken
swiftly on the circuit breaker though
sophie
it's not me who is saying um alone we
should do this this was the advice of
sage scientists to the government a
month ago
they believe this would be the most
effective way of arresting the spread of
the virus across
the whole country and i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty shocked that
just get let me just finish this one i
am pretty shocked and i i think most
people are pretty shocked that the
government for a month has ignored that
advice and done nothing
just to be crystal clear because my
question was should grow to manchester
go into tier three of restrictions
well we definitely need additional
measures here tier three restrictions
with support with an extra package of
support so that the restrictions
have the best chance of actually being
effective but my preference labor's
preference
as you know it's a yes but my preference
is that
labour's call as you know is for a
national circuit breaker because we
think
in the long run that will be more
effective more quickly
than this constant patchwork of as you
say checking in and then never being
able to check out of local restrictions
that people don't understand
and where already we can see they're not
proving effective
uh it's interesting to say uh how um
some of the restrictions aren't proving
effective because of course restrictions
will only be effective if people
actually follow
the rules and the government's saying
that police are going to have access
to people who have been contacted and
told to self-isolate do you think that's
a good idea
well i noticed that the chief medical
officer said he was very
worried about that because of course it
might deter people from even going to
have a test and clearly we of course
people must obey the rules
and it's really important that people
understand the rules so they need to be
communicated very clearly but at the
same time we absolutely want people who
are worried that they have symptoms to
go and be tested and
and not to deter them from doing so and
i do question you know where the police
resources are going to come from to to
follow up
um all this information so um i
really wonder just how much substance
there is to
this or whether it's it's just some kind
of political announcement that actually
isn't
going to deliver in practice okay uh and
just
finally uh well we've got you uh marcus
rashid the manchester united footballer
is asking the government to provide free
school meals
to children when schools are on holiday
now number 10 have said it's not for
schools to provide
meals when they're actually on holiday
they've got a point haven't they
no they haven't got a point because
families are in a desperate situation at
the moment
you know parents are losing jobs because
of the covert crisis
they're really worrying about how
they're going to put food on the table
for their children we're talking about
people on desperately low incomes sophie
really worried about how they're going
to feed their kids uh and
you know i'm standing you know half a
mile from old trafford i pay huge
tribute to what marcus rashford has done
to bring this to public attention and
did persuade the government that they
would need to provide school meals over
the summer holidays labor's calling for
that to be continued
during this academic year while we're in
the depths of this crisis
right through all the school holidays
and half terms this year it's so
important that these children get a
proper healthy meal
we know families are under huge
financial pressure and this would make
an enormous difference to them